secretary mayorkas has refused to
address this crisis but we won't
he regularly lies to the American people
claiming that the southern border is
closed I've been there it's wide open
Alejandro mallarkas has forsaken his
sworn oath to protect the Homeland I can
promise you Texans aren't going to put
up with us anymore and this body this
Congress this republican-led Congress
needs to hold in uh Alejandro my orcas
accountable he needs to be fired he
needs to be removed from office under
the tools under the Constitution
20 House Republicans and a number of
Border officials are pushing to impeach
DHS secretary mayorkas as we learn
they've already been more than half a
million migrant encounters at the
Southwest border since October
Congressman Andy Biggs for County house
oversight committee and is leading the
push to impeach mayorkas and joins us
now Congressman good morning to you
let's get into specifics here on what
grounds are you calling to impeach my
orcas how would you go about doing this
well first of all we'll have an
investigation to go through and make
sure that we're not rushing on anything
but here's the deal he is violating
title eight so title eight requires him
to have maintain detention over these
individuals until they've had their
immigration status determined he has
said we're going to release them in fact
they've released over a million people
into the country who are not here
legally he is also committed we think
he's committed perjury it looks like
that I mean he's told us that the
borders operationally secure it is not
so that you've got two two crimes right
there Then you have additional facts
that he has told ice that we're not
going to remove people who already have
been through courth had due process
there's 1.2 million of them that have
been ordered to be removed he said we're
not going to look for them we're not
going to remove them fourth thing is
he's provided incentives for people to
come into this country illegally the
fifth thing is he's provided specific
breaks for certain countries who've sent
masses of people here where he's gone
after other people all of those things
indicate that he's committed High crimes
and misdemeanors and that's the standard
for impeachment Congressman beyond
impeaching my orcas what are Republicans
going to do when they take over the
house next month in order to stem this
crisis does that include withholding
funding does that include investigations
that lead to significant tangible
changes what
yeah so so the way it would work is if
we can if this Omnibus doesn't get
through and we still have a a chance to
use the budget as leverage we will
leverage the budget to make sure that
you finish the wall and you provide the
resources necessary to the border patrol
to enforce title eight and you don't do
away with title 42 those are all tools
to stop what's going on at the border
the second thing is exactly what you say
you have to bring people in and hold
them accountable to the public and to
Congress for the policies that they that
they've deliberately intentionally
willfully put into place that are
drawing people to this country at the
rate of last weekend over sixteen
thousand encounters and that doesn't
include the godaways which in the Tucson
sector some days is over a thousand
people known to be getting away yeah and
Congressman in both El Paso and
Brownsville two cities that are nowhere
close to each other those areas are so
overwhelmed right now that border patrol
is just Mass releasing migrants onto the
streets and these people have nowhere to
go so they are essentially homeless and
I remember under the Trump
Administration Democrats were incensed
over the lack of beds that migrants had
at border patrol facilities so where is
that outrage now
well they're they're mute on the subject
because they say we can't even get them
to admit there there is a problem on the
border some of them say that it's it's
absolutely okay the only there's only
one Democrat that I know of that's
talking about that but I mean just just
to your point they're they're going to
start releasing into the community in
Yuma as well they have a facility that
they put up 12 holds 1200 people but
most days has over 3 000 people and
there's only one NGO small facilities
the hospital there is being overrun by
people being released into the community
who just pop up into the ER into their
maternity room so this is going on all
along the border and uh and it's going
to be spreading throughout the entire
country it has to because there's just
millions of people that are flooding the
border and when you look at these
numbers the images we're seeing
currently on our screen these are bad
but this is before title 42 goes away
imagine how much worse this is going to
look when three times more people are
coming every day it is a frightening
thought best of luck trying to solve
this crisis congressman Andy Biggs and
we thank you for joining us this morning
very much appreciated
thank you thank you thank you so much
Congressman we appreciate it I'm Steve
Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley
Earhart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis